CITY
CENTERING PASS TO DUCHENE
CLEANED UP IN FRFRNOT
ABLE TO SQUEEZE IT BACK INTO THE
SAN JOSE ZONE.
ICING.
TOMASINO SCORED AGAINST SEATTLE,
AND THEY DO GET ONE HERE IT.
AND AS MCCARRON COMES OUT OF THE
CORNER HE JUST KIND OF ONE TIMES
NET.
MOVES LEFT AND THEN BACK
AND NOW SIMEK.R BURNS.
MIDDLETON!
AND SAROS GOT SQUARE, PUSHED
ACROSSTHIS
ONE TO MEIER AT THE BLUE LINE.
TIMO SHOOT, OFF THE BAR.W IT IS
HE RECOVERS WITH A GREAT SAVE
OFF GRANLUND
CHANCE HERE,SAVED BY SAROS
MATT LUFF CLEANS UP THE GARBAGE.
IT IS 4-0.EN HE JUST GAME.
ALL OF THEM ASSISTS.
NIETO CIRCLE AROUND.
AND
GOLD SHOULDER.
AND THAT IS JUST ENOUGH TO HIM
MICHAEL MCCARRON MAKES IT 6-0 IN
A RUN AWAY FOR THE PREDATORS FRT
POLL DRAG.
REEDY HAS TO GO AND TAKE A
BETTER ANGNG POST.
>> Bret: OFF THAT RIGHT POSTE SH
AND TRENIN JUST T
AND THEY SCORE ON THE REBOUND.
AND IT IS GRANLUND
THROUGH NUMBER 59 9